le calme avant la tempête il est arrivé
le premier de la région de poitiers pour
défendre sa liberté le docteur peschier
est dans l'oeil du cyclone
les victimes sont venues en nombre pour
assister aux débats leur avocat celui de
la clinique saint-vincent y compris ont
aiguisé leurs arguments il aurait décelé
dans les 17 hommes du dossier la preuve
que le docteur fait chier n'aurait pas
respecté les termes de son contrôle
judiciaire il est difficile de
comprendre que parce que le docteur
pelechian une assise financière
importante
ils soient toujours sous contrôle
judiciaire pour moi pour moi il ya eu
violation du contrôle judiciaire
je le dirai personnel je le dirai le cas
car c'est là toute la différence cette
fois les avocats des parties civiles
seront entendus un bras de fer capital
qui peut jeter le docteur pesci en
prison dans les heures qui viennent
aujourd'hui elles vont venir
rééquilibrer ou déséquilibrés d'aucun
apprécieront pour tenter de deux
d'obtenir d'obtenir ce qui pourrait être
qualifié de remontage judiciaires de la
part des parties civiles à savoir
qu'elles viennent aujourd'hui pour
obtenir la détention est l'auteur péché
on attend de la chambre de l'instruction
le même courage qu'a eue le juge des
libertés et de la détention il ya un
mois de cela lorsque nous avons plaidé
avec mes confrères et on attend
effectivement que le docteur pesci
ressorte libre de cette audience
le duel se déroule à huis clos le palais
retient son souffle